hi everyone my name is kadyardan and i'm
a graduate student at university of
washington
today i'm going to talk about an
important extension we made to the cindy
algorithm that is able to identify
rational or implicit equation from the
measurement data
we call it cindy pi a robust algorithm
for parallel implicit sparse
identification of non-neurodynamics
the original cindy algorithm can only
identify dynamical system that has a
relatively easy right hand side
structures
but now using cindy pi we can identify
much more complicated equations
with much more complicated right hand
side structures
if you're interested in our papers
please feel free to check it out using
the links below moreover after its
publication the cindy pi has been used
in many different packages such as
pricing the python package or
data-driven differential equation.gl
julia packages
if you want to use cindypi for your
research and work please please also
check out those packages as well
okay now i'm going to talk about some
big pictures of what they're trying to
do here what we're trying to do is that
modeling dynamical system using the
measurement data
this dynamical system could be some
robotic system such as a double pendulum
on the card or maybe some high
dimensional pde system such as flow past
the cylinder or maybe some complex
chemical reaction model such as busy
reaction
and in order to do this we're going to
measure a bunch of data from the
dynamics of our interest and using
sophisticated machine learning algorithm
to figure out the best equations that
can describe our dynamics while at the
same time best fit our data set
to be more specific we're interested in
identifying differential equation such
as x dot d cos fx
and there are many algorithms that can
do that for example the sparse
identification of non-aerodynamics
algorithm
aka cindy
what the cindy algorithm can do is
generate a parsimonious yet interpretive
model for us
and in the cindy framework what is
usually given to us is the full state
measurement of the system for example x1
and x2 of this wonderful oscillator
and what we have to estimate is the
state derivative such as x1 dot and x2
dot
and what we have to design is a library
with many different candidate functions
those candidate functions represent our
belief of what kind of terms that might
show up on our right hand side term
and next when we gather all those
information we can provide them to the
cindy algorithm and the cindy will try
to solve for a sparse promoting list
square problem
this problem is going to generate a
sparse vector c that only selects a
field term from our candidate libraries
such that we can represent our left hand
side derivative
for example after the cd regression the
term x2 has been selected from the
feature library
to represent our state derivative x1 dot
and the features x1 x2 x1 squared times
x2 has been selected from our library to
best represent our state derivative x2
dot
and once we have this sparse vector c
right we can finally do a reconstruction
step to figure out the symbolic form of
the dynamical equations we're looking
for
with some modification on the cindy
framework the rudi add-on made it
possible to identify pd equations as
well and they call it pdefine
for example suppose we have a non-linear
pde equations we can measure this pde
equation spatially and gather its
measurement data
next what we can do is build up a
library with many different candidate
terms and try to solve for a sparse
promoting regression problem and this
spar sparse promoting regression problem
is going to generate the sparse vector c
that only selects a field term from our
library to best represent our derivative
a partial derivative u of t
and finally again we can do a
reconstruction step to find out the
symbolic form of the pde equations
although pdefined and cindy pi can be
applied to many applications they do
have some drawbacks for example they
cannot be used to identify this rational
system
for example suppose we have a system x
dot equals to minus x divided by sine x
and you're trying to identify it using
cindy
so one immediate question you're going
to have is how should i design my
library
remember we have to add different
candidate terms right that might show up
on our right hand side and now since we
have a rational term we might also have
to add some rational candidate functions
in our libraries
and without any prior knowledge of what
kind of numerators and denominators we
might have we will end up with a huge
library with infinitely many combination
of the numerators and denominators
and this large library this large
library is not a good sign for us
because usually a large library means
the conditioning of our matrix is going
to getting worse and during the sparse
regression process
it's going to be really noise sensitive
so in order to fix this problem the mega
nadal come up with an idea called
implicit cindy
what implicit cindy realized is that
instead of directly identifying this
rational term we can identify its
analogous system which is an implicit
equation
for example if i multiply this one plus
x term on both sides of the equation i'm
going to end up with an
implicit equation
and once i can identify this implicit
equation i can symbolically back solve
for x dot and figure out the rational
form of my dynamical system
in order to do so to make an adult a lot
of combination of state vector x and
state derivative x dot in the library
and then they try to solve for a null
space vector a sparse known space vector
that's going to only select a few terms
from our library such that when we add
them up it's going to generate our
implicit equation
and once we have our implicit equation
we can symbolically solve for x dot and
get the rational dynamics we're looking
for and that's the idea behind implicit
cindy
and implicit cindy also has one drawback
which is it is noise sensitive
remember we have to solve for the null
space of the library matrix and the null
space does not exist when your metric is
full rank which is always the case when
your measurement data is contaminated by
the noise
in order to fix this problem you have to
do some post-processing process and
again this post-processing process is
also more sensitive
so the question is how we can improve
this
well we can use sindy pi and now i'm
going to talk about a really pedagogical
example and show you the core idea
behind the sindipai algorithm
suppose we want to identify this
rational equation x dot equals to 1 plus
x divided by sine x
so according to implicit cindy we know
identifying these rational equations
equals to identifying this implicit
equation
and if we make a further observation
here we can find out this implicit
equation actually has three non-implicit
form
and by non-implicit form i mean we can
put one term belongs to our implicit
equation put it on the left-hand side
and put the remaining terms on the
right-hand side such that our equation
is not implicit anymore
and now suppose that i tell you that x
dot times sine x belongs to this
implicit equation and you're required to
figure out the remaining part of the
simplicity equation
so what you can do is put this x dot
times sine x term on the left hand side
and build up a library on the right hand
side and perform a sparse regression
such that you can figure out the correct
terms from the library to best represent
your left hand side term x dot times
sine x and after the sparse regression
you're going to pick up 1 and x
from your library which is the remaining
term of this implicit equation
and similarly if i tell you that x
belongs to this implicit equation and
you have to figure out the remaining
part of this implicit equation so what
you can do is put this x term on the
left hand side and build up a library on
the right hand side then perform a
sparse regression such that you can
figure out the remaining terms
of this implicit equation and when you
do that you can pick out the term one
and x times sine x dot times sine x from
the library
and similar thing also happens if i tell
you that one belongs to this implicit
equation
so by these really easy examples what we
did is just generalizing the cindy
algorithm
in the original cindy algorithm what we
always put on the left hand side is our
state derivative but now we realize we
can actually put any terms belong to our
system on the left-hand side and perform
a sparse regression to figure out the
remaining terms
and once we do that we can get this
alternative non-implicit representation
of our implicit equation and that's how
we do the system identification using
sindhipi
okay
now you might say
what happens if i do not know what kind
of term belong to amma to my implicit
equation
because previously i'm telling you okay
x dot times sine x belong to this
equation right but in real life
especially when you're modeling a black
box system you're not going to know what
kind of term belongs to our equation
so what we can do is basically guess
what kind of terms that will show up
to do so we can build up a left-hand
side library and also a right hand side
library this right hand side library
contains all the candidate terms that
might show up on the right hand side
well the left-hand side library is going
to be used to our as our guess of what
kind of term belong to this implicit
equation
for example we can pick out this term 1
from our left-hand side library put it
here and in order to get rid of trivial
solutions such as 1 equals to 1 we have
to delete that same term 1 from our
right hand side library now we are ready
to perform a sparse regression and since
this term one belongs to this implicit
equation after the sparse regression
we're going to figure out the remaining
part of our implicit dynamics
which is
which is x dot times sine x minus x
and similarly we can test our term
x
now x also belongs to this implicit
equation so after you perform a sparse
regression you're going to have a sparse
model and the term one and x dot times
sine x is going to be selected and
moreover when you test out this model
this sparse model on the testing data
it's going to generate a really low
prediction arrow
now let's try out x square remember x
squared doesn't belong to this implicit
equation right
so when you do the sparse regression for
most of the time you're going to overfit
your library you're going to have not a
sparse model
and this non-sparse model is not going
to perform a really good job on the
testing data
similarly now let's try out x dot x dot
doesn't belong to this implicit equation
so as you might have guessed after the
sparse regression you're not going to
have a sparse model and you're going to
overfit your library and this model is
not going to perform a good job on the
testing data
next let's try out x times x dot and
similarly again not the sparse model
and this model is not going to perform a
good job on the testing data
next we can try out x dot times sine x
now this term belongs to our implicit
equation so after splash regression
you're going to have a sparse model
and finally we can try out x dot times
cosine x
so from these examples we know we can
actually put any term on the left hand
side and perform a guess
guessing what kind of terms that might
show up in our implicit equation such
that we can solve for a sparse
regression problem to figure out a bunch
of candidate models
and moreover each sparse regression
problem is independent of each other
which means we can use a parallel
toolbox to speed up the solving process
that's why we call it cindy pipe where
pi stands for parallel and implicit
and this and the similar idea can also
be shown in the johns paper
okay so one important observation we
just made is if you make a correct guess
you're always going to generate for most
of the time you're going to generate a
sparse and accurate model and if you
made a wrong guess you're uh you're more
likely to generate a dense and
inaccurate model and this important
observation is going to be used as our
model selection criteria
moreover instead of solving each
individual sparse regression problem we
can
come up with some constrained
optimization problem such that we can
solve all the candidate model at once
for example we can build up this
optimization problem saying our
left-hand side library equals to itself
times a sparse matrix
and in order to get rid of the trivial
solution such as identity matrix we have
to constrain our
sparse matrix such that its diagonal
element is equals to zero
and each column of this sparse matrix
represents one candidate model
and we can use the same model selection
criteria to figure out which model
performs good and which model performs a
really bad job and such that we can
figure out the correct model
and incorrect model
to give you further understanding of
what i mean by accurate model and
inaccurate model let's look at an
example michelius mountain dynamics
suppose we want to identify this
rational system then we know that if we
make our left hand side guess as x times
x dot we're going to generate a sparse
model usually performs a really good job
on the testing data
however when we make a run guess such as
x dot times sine x on the left hand side
we're going to overfit the library
and when we test those two models on the
testing data and we can find out this
sparse model generates around machine
epsilon prediction arrow where this
non-sparse model which overfit our
library is going to generate orders of
magnitude much higher prediction arrow
that's when we know by looking at this
plot that the correct guess should be x
dot times x and the correct model should
be
this sparse model
and finally we can symbolically solve
for x dot and get this rational system
that we're looking for
okay now let's talk about uh in
performance improvement of the cindy pi
algorithm
remember we do not have to solve for
null space anymore right using cindy pi
so we can directly improve our
noise robustness of the cindy
pi algorithm for example when we compare
the noise robustness performance of
sindipai and implicit cindy on michelius
mountain dynamics we find out cindy pi
has orders of magnitude much more noise
robustness than implicit in the
algorithm
moreover we find out cindy pi can use
less data point to identify rational
equations than implicits in the
algorithm
for example we tested both algorithms
using each glycolysis model and we find
out cindy pi can use around 10 times
less data point to correctly identify
this x6 dot term in each glycolysis
model
and with this improved noise robustness
and data efficiency we can now finally
tackle a
rational pde equations
for example uh we compare the
performance of cindy pi and pdefine on
this modified kdv equation
this modified kdb equation has a
rational term 2g naught divided by 1
plus u
and as you gradually increase the g
naught value uh the rational term is
going to play an important part in the
whole dynamics as you can see on these
figures
when g naught is zero that means we do
not have any rational dynamics both
cindy pi and pdf i can find out the
correct equations of our system and when
g naught is small we find out that
pdefined starts to add some constant
terms and tuning its candidate terms
parameters to compensate for that
rational dynamics
and when g naught is really large the
pde fine will finally suffers it will
overfit the library and the final model
is not going to be correct on the
contrary the cindy pi is going to
correct
select the correct model at all
different levels of g naught
after we know this we start to challenge
ourselves with much more complicated
problem such as bc reaction
bz reaction is a really complicated
chemical reaction model and its
simplified pde equations can be seen
here the simplified pde equations has a
rational term which cannot be identified
using pdefined before
so what we did is we simulated the
simulation
data
in the matlab and we provided the
simulation data to this indie pi and the
cindy pi correctly identifies this
rational and implicit equation and also
the remaining dynamics of the system
and when we simulate this identified
equation
in matlab we find out it matches really
good with the ground truth
the second example we looked at is
double pendulum so double pendulum looks
pretty easy right it only has two links
but actually double pendulum is a really
chaotic and non-linear system moreover
it has a pretty nasty rational terms
pretty complicated rational ode
so we simulated double pendulum in
matlab with different noise level and we
provided those data set to cindy pi
and we find out cindy pi can correctly
identify the odes of double pendulum
under different noise level and when we
simulate this identified odes forward in
time it matches really good with the
ground tools
all right the next examples we used is a
system with control input if you're a
control expert who is interested in
dynamical system with control input the
cindy pi can also tackle that
for example the single pendulum with
control
input it has a rational term in its ode
so when we simulated the system in
matlab under different noise level and
we provided the simulation data to cindy
pi we find out cindy pi can generate the
correct model and when we simulate this
correct model uh it matches really good
with the ground rules
and as our final examples we even tried
even more challenging tasks for example
identifying physical loss from the data
set
many physical laws such as hamiltonian
or lagrangian actually has an implicit
form for example the double pendulum's
euler lagrangian equation has an
implicit form so when we simulate the
double pendulum and building the correct
libraries we find out the cindy pie can
figure out the correct physical loss
that's hidden beneath this data set and
in this case the cindy pi correctly
identified all the lagrangian equation
from the from the simulation data of
double pendulum
okay
now in summary we did develop a new
algorithm called zindipi this algorithm
can parallelly solve for implicit or
rational problem and moreover it is more
noise robust and requires less data
point
finally it can identify physical laws
from the data
if you're interested in other
papers please feel free to check it out
and if you want to use cindy pi for your
research at work please also check out
the packages below
and i would like to thank my
collaborators professor steve ronton and
professor nissan quits at university of
washington and thank you all for
listening